Sì, dai basta, vi lasciate parlare?
No, ragazzi, grazie mille, però mi sembra che ci siano aspettative lievemente esagerate, anche perché sapete quest'anno il tema è le origini e io mi sono detto beh che ci vuole, qualche anno fa abbiamo fatto come scoppiano le guerre ed era venuto bene mi sembra e quest'anno facciamo le guerre civili, sarà più o meno la stessa cosa?
Non è più o meno la stessa cosa, perché spiegare come scoppiano le guerre, beh va bene, nella storia umana che due paesi abbiano interessi contrastanti e si vogliano poco bene, anzi per niente, e che a un certo punto finiscano per decidere di risolvere le loro questioni con la guerra è una cosa banale, non è tanto difficile spiegare com'è che succede.
E invece spiegare com'è che succede che un paese dove si parla la stessa lingua, ci sono le stesse tradizioni, a un certo punto si spacca, a un punto tale che scoppia una guerra civile, e beh è molto più complicato spiegarlo.
Questo vuol dire che avete pagato un biglietto per una lezione che sarà assai impegnativa, più lunga del solito, più complessa del solito, adesso vi sembra di desiderarlo ma vedrete, comunque stasera noi parliamo forse della meno conosciuta fra le tre guerre civili che toccheremo in queste tre tappe,
e cioè la guerra civile inglese del XVII secolo. Cominciamo dalla fine, siamo a Londra, è il 30 gennaio del 1649 e nel centro di Londra, a Whitehall, è stato eretto un patibolo.
È destinato al re d'Inghilterra e di Scozia, Carlo I, che viene condotto lì a piedi dal suo palazzo di St. James, che è a due passi.
Sul patibolo gli permettono di fare un ultimo discorso, in cui il re dichiara che lui ha sempre desiderato la libertà del suo popolo,
ma che la libertà consiste nell'essere governati e non nel prendere parte al governo, che è una cosa che non spetta al popolo.
Sono le due del pomeriggio quando il re mette la testa sul ceppo, recita una preghiera, poi tende le mani per far segno che è pronto.
E il boia, che è stato assunto in segreto, è mascherato e nessuno sa chi sia, il boia gli taglia la testa con un solo colpo.
Anni dopo un predicatore protestante, che da ragazzo aveva assistito all'esecuzione, ricorderà che dalla folla era salito un lamento come non avevo mai sentito
e desidero non sentire mai più di nuovo.
La testa del re viene mostrata al popolo, il giorno dopo viene di nuovo ricucita al corpo, che viene imbalsamato con un guenti e sepolto nella cappella del castello di Windsor.
Allora, da quando Costantino si era convertito al cristianesimo, 1300 anni prima, molti imperatori e re cristiani erano stati assassinati.
Altri erano morti in battaglia.
Gli inglesi stessi avevano assassinato nel Medioevo almeno due dei loro re, Edoardo II e Riccardo II.
Ma Carlo I è il primo re d'Europa che muore dopo essere stato processato legalmente e condannato a morte per alto tradimento.
L'esecuzione di Carlo I è il punto d'arrivo di una guerra civile che è durata sei anni.
Eppure poco tempo prima che scoppiasse quella guerra, l'Inghilterra si considerava un paese benedetto dalla pace.
Portiamo indietro l'orologio di una dozzina d'anni.
In Inghilterra nel 600 era di gran moda uno spettacolo che chiamavano il mask.
Erano rappresentazioni in costume che univano musica, canto, balletto, scenografia.
Erano di gran moda anche a corte, si davano dei mask in cui il re, la regina, loro stessi provavano per mesi la loro parte.
E il contenuto era sempre allegorico secondo il gusto dell'epoca.
Nel 1637 quando l'Europa è in preda alla guerra dei trent'anni, una delle guerre più spaventose della sua storia,
l'Inghilterra è l'unico grande paese che non è coinvolto nella guerra.
Nel 1637 la corporazione degli avvocati di Londra dà un mask in onore del re,
il più costoso mai visto fino allora, con più di 200 partecipanti.
E il tema è il trionfo della pace.
In quell'anno Carlo I parlando con i suoi nipoti tedeschi, i figli di sua sorella che ha sposato un principe tedesco,
i suoi nipoti tedeschi che vengono dalla Germania devastata in modo inenarrabile dalla guerra dei trent'anni,
in quell'anno, in quel 37, a Carlo I viene da dire, gli scappa di dire, che lui è il re più felice della cristianità.
In realtà quella felicità era illusoria.
E nell'Inghilterra fermentava lo scontento, ma il re non ne aveva il minimo sospetto.
E non ne aveva il minimo sospetto perché lo stile di vita di un re di quell'epoca lo separava completamente dal suo popolo.
L'etichetta di corte sembrava fatta apposta per isolare il re dal paese e farlo vivere in un mondo irreale.
Tutte le corti dell'epoca avevano un'etichetta estremamente rigida che trasformava
l'esistenza quotidiana del re in una specie di spettacolo.
La corte inglese è forse però appunto la più formale d'Europa.
Il re d'Inghilterra è l'unico re d'Europa che viene servito a tavola da cortigiani nobili in ginocchio.
E la gente comune non ha nessun contatto con il re.
Il re naturalmente vive sempre in pubblico, sempre sotto gli occhi di qualcuno,
ma questo qualcuno sono i cortigiani.
Il popolo normale non lo vede mai, non lo incontra mai,
tranne nelle due occasioni, due volte all'anno, ecco, due volte all'anno,
il re d'Inghilterra, come il re di Francia,
tocca i malati di scrofola.
Perché da secoli in quei due regni c'è la tradizione, la convinzione popolare
che la scrofola è un male speciale e che i re hanno un potere magico
e possono guarire i malati di scrofola.
Non stupitevi che nel Seicento ci siano queste cose,
la società e la mentalità del Seicento non sono mica tanto diverse
da quelle di tre secoli prima.
I re toccano i malati e i malati vengono a farsi toccare.
Ma per essere ammessi a essere toccati dal re,
per sperare di guarire da questa malattia che tutti chiamano il male del re,
per essere ammessi i malati devono avere un certificato con triplice firma
di un parroco, di un amministratore della loro parrocchia
e di un giudice di pace.
Carlo non ha nessuna idea di quali sono i veri sentimenti del paese
nei suoi confronti e nei confronti del suo governo e della sua corte.
E mi fermo sulla corte perché proprio non tanto sulla persona del re all'inizio
ma sull'ambiente che lo circonda, la corte, si appunta il fastidio
e l'ostilità della popolazione, del paese.
Il discredito della corte è cominciato già al tempo di suo padre,
Giacomo I. Prima ancora regnava Elisabetta.
Elisabetta era popolarissima, c'era anche una grande capacità propagandistica
ma Elisabetta era davvero popolarissima.
Morte Elisabetta senza eredi, sul trono d'Inghilterra sale Giacomo I, re di Scozia.
E già sotto Giacomo I, di colpo, l'opinione pubblica comincia invece
a diffidare della corte e dei cortigiani.
Bisogna dire che il re, come dire, fa di tutto,
sembra fare di tutto per incoraggiare l'opinione pubblica a diffidare.
Il re ha un primo ministro, il duca di Buckingham, molto più giovane di lui,
un favorito, come si diceva allora, ma che di fatto governa il regno.
Il duca di Buckingham è detestato perché vende tutto,
vende titoli nobiliari, vescovadi, qualunque cosa uno voglia,
se paga il duca lo ottiene.
E il re Giacomo ha una relazione sessuale con il suo primo ministro,
il duca di Buckingham, è un fatto, all'epoca era un pettegolezzo,
oggi è un fatto accertato, abbiamo le loro lettere.
Il re Giacomo scriveva al suo primo ministro
Dio ti benedica, dolce figlio e moglie,
e conceda che tu sia per sempre di conforto al tuo caro papà e marito.
Ora, queste lettere ovviamente il pubblico non le conosceva,
le conosciamo noi oggi, che magari non abbiamo nessun motivo
di scandalizzarci davanti a una relazione del genere,
ma immaginate l'opinione pubblica del XVII secolo.
Tutti sanno che c'è un favorito che governa il regno
e che il re ha una strana relazione con questo favorito,
tanto più giovane di lui.
E in Inghilterra dilagano i pettegolezzi sulle orge della corte,
sul fatto che il re e i suoi amici hanno rapporti sessuali
e si ubriacano.
Poi Giacomo I muore, subentra suo figlio Carlo,
che tanti anni più tardi finirà sul patibolo a Londra.
Carlo è un personaggio molto diverso,
è un personaggio austero, freddo,
che non dà adito a pettegolezzi,
ma non si libera del duca di Buckingham,
con cui in realtà è amico e di cui anche lui è un po' succube.
Buckingham continua a governare l'Inghilterra per qualche anno,
finché non viene assassinato e il paese esulta
e il suo assassino viene celebrato nelle ballate
come un grande eroe dell'Inghilterra.
In altre parole, l'immagine della corte è irrecuperabile.
Oltretutto il re ha sposato una principessa francese,
la regina Enrichetta è francese,
in un paese, l'Inghilterra, che detesta i francesi,
è cattolica, in un paese dove la maggioranza è ferocemente protestante,
è molto più giovane di suo marito, ama il ballo, il teatro,
gli ambasciatori veneziani scrivono che la corte inglese
è la più sontuosa e la più allegra del mondo.
Agli occhi della maggioranza degli inglesi
questa non è una cosa positiva.
L'Inghilterra profonda, che vive lontana dalla corte,
si afferma l'idea che il re e la corte,
la famiglia reale, i cortigiani e i ministri
sono un corpo estraneo,
che la corte non c'entra niente col paese.
Un grande storico, Lawrence Stone,
ha espresso questa cosa in modo memorabile,
quindi cito lui, anziché provare a dirlo con parole mie.
Il paese era virtuoso, la corte malvagia.
Il paese era parsimonioso, la corte scialava.
Il paese era onesto, la corte corrotta.
Il paese era casto e eterosessuale,
la corte promiscua e omosessuale.
Il paese era sobrio, la corte ubriaca.
Il paese era patriottico, la corte filo straniera.
Il paese era protestante, persino puritano.
La corte era pericolosamente filo papista.
Fermiamoci su quest'ultimo aspetto,
che è cruciale.
Perché?
Perché la religione è ancora fondamentale
in questa società,
che ripeto, non è uscita realmente dal Medioevo,
e una delle caratteristiche del nostro passato medievale
è proprio il fatto della pervasività della religione,
l'importanza che ha la religione per la gente.
Abbiamo detto che il paese era puritano.
Cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire che ufficialmente,
ufficialmente in Inghilterra,
dopo la riforma protestante,
esisteva una sola chiesa,
la chiesa anglicana,
con a capo il re.
Guardate che questo aspetto religioso
è di enorme importanza,
cioè stiamo già entrando nel discorso
delle cause della guerra civile,
in cui anche fattori politici,
e lo vedremo,
avranno un ruolo gigantesco,
ma la dimensione religiosa è fondamentale.
Ora, la chiesa anglicana
è una chiesa protestante
in quanto rifiuta l'autorità del Papa,
anzi, aborre quello che loro chiamano
il papismo,
ma in realtà nel suo funzionamento concreto
la chiesa anglicana dell'epoca
assomiglia molto alla chiesa cattolica.
è una chiesa autoritaria
con la sua gerarchia di parroci,
di vescovi,
è una chiesa che si aspetta
che i fedeli si lasciano guidare
come un gregge
senza discutere
gli insegnamenti
che arrivano dal pulpito.
Solo che l'Inghilterra del 600
che si sta avviando,
benché sia un paese ancora medievale,
ma si sta anche avviando
a essere il paese più moderno d'Europa,
l'Inghilterra.
E per esempio
è un paese dove c'è sempre più gente
che sa leggere e scrivere.
E saper leggere vuol dire
essere esposti alla circolazione
della propaganda,
dei fogli di notizie.
E un popolo dove molti
sanno leggere e scrivere,
anche fra i poveri,
dove il sentimento religioso
è molto radicato
e dove comanda una chiesa di stato
con una visione molto autoritaria,
voi capite che questa è una ricetta
per la nascita del dissenso.
E l'Inghilterra è piena
di movimenti dissidenti,
dissidenti religiosi.
Sette, come dicono le autorità.
Sono loro i puritani.
Cominciano come gruppi di lettura
non autorizzati,
laici che si radunano
per leggere insieme la Bibbia,
perché sanno leggere,
non hanno bisogno del parroco.
E pian piano finiscono
per rifiutare la chiesa ufficiale.
Sono protestanti rigorosi,
anche fanatici.
Odiano tutti quegli elementi cattolici
che sono rimasti nel rituale
della chiesa anglicana.
I crocifissi,
le immagini sacre,
per i puritani
idolatria e superstizione.
I puritani sono favorevoli appunto
alla lettura personale della Bibbia.
Vorrebbero che i pastori
fossero eletti dai fedeli,
che non ci fossero vescovi
a comandarli,
o addirittura che fossero
i laici stessi
a predicare agli altri.
Ora, io direi che se ci fermassimo qui
potremmo anche dire
beh, sono piuttosto simpatici i puritani.
Hanno un'impostazione decisamente
democratica, anti-autoritaria.
Naturalmente dobbiamo fare
il quadro completo.
I puritani sono degli integralisti religiosi,
vanno vestiti solo di nero,
vorrebbero vietare qualunque sport,
qualunque divertimento,
il ballo,
chiudere i teatri
nell'Inghilterra
dove pochi anni prima
è morto Shakespeare.
I puritani si considerano
il popolo eletto,
il nuovo Israele,
e si aspettano che Dio
sterminerà i loro avversari
e li condurrà
in una nuova Gerusalemme.
E questo magari a noi piacerebbe di meno
se dovessimo incontrarli.
Però il puritanesimo
comunque significa davvero
rimettere in discussione
l'obbligo di obbedire
alle autorità.
Come disse uno dei grandi pensatori
del Seicento inglese,
Hobbes,
Thomas Hobbes,
che non aveva nessuna simpatia
per tutto questo,
cito Hobbes,
dopo che la Bibbia
fu tradotta in inglese,
ogni uomo,
anzi,
ogni ragazzo
e ogni ragazzina
che sapessero leggere
l'inglese
si convinsero
di parlare
con Dio Onnipotente
e di capire
quel che diceva.
Hobbes naturalmente
durante la guerra civile
sarà dalla parte del re
e sarà costretto
a scappare all'estero.
Perché in effetti
il punto è che
la politica del re Carlo
lo porta
allo scontro
diretto
con i puritani,
con il dissenso religioso.
Perché?
Perché lui è il capo
della Chiesa d'Inghilterra
e pretende
che tutti i suoi sudditi
appartengano
alla Chiesa d'Inghilterra
e obbediscano
ai vescovi anglicani.
Questa cosa
dei vescovi
facciamo attenzione
perché è particolarmente
significativa.
Nel mondo protestante
quasi sempre
è stata rimessa
in discussione
l'idea di una Chiesa
appunto
gerarchica
con un capo
e poi i vescovi
in Inghilterra
tutti sanno
che se il capo
della Chiesa
è il re
vuol dire
che i vescovi
li sceglie lui
e che i vescovi
non hanno nessuna autonomia
si danno tante arie
e vogliono comandare
ma in realtà
sono al servizio
del re.
È una vecchia storia
già al tempo
di Elisabetta
ci sono testimonianze
sul fatto
che il punto debole
della Chiesa anglicana
è proprio il fatto
che la gente
che i vescovi
non riescono
a farsi rispettare
come scrisse
al tempo
di Elisabetta
un arcivescovo
i messaggeri
di Cristo
sono stimati
tamquam
excrementa
mundi
come gli
escrementi
del mondo
ma Carlo
è deciso
a mettere fine
a tutto questo
e a ristabilire
l'autorità
dell'episcopato
anglicano
e l'uomo
a cui affida
questo compito
è l'arcivescovo
di Canterbury
William Lode
che è un personaggio
cruciale
della nostra storia
l'arcivescovo
William Lode
è l'uomo
che convince
il re
e non fa fatica
a convincerlo
che bisogna
per salvare
insieme
il trono
e l'altare
bisogna stroncare
il dissenso
religioso
l'arcivescovo
era un uomo
di origini modeste
figlio di un commerciante
molto colto
secondo gli osservatori
contemporanei
non molto
ben educati
lo descrivono
come un ometto
rubizzo
irritabile
e intollerante
in realtà
l'arcivescovo
William Lode
qualche dubbio
nel suo inconscio
doveva averlo
ma non
non lo voleva
ammettere
neanche lui
e poi loro
dell'inconscio
sapevano meno
di quello che
pensiamo di sapere
noi
sta di fatto
che l'arcivescovo
teneva un diario
in cui annotava
i sogni
che faceva
specialmente
quando faceva
dei sogni inquietanti
una volta
sognò
che il re
voleva sposare
la vedova
di un pastore
protestante
e che lui
l'arcivescovo
doveva celebrare
il matrimonio
ma non riusciva
a trovare
nel libro liturgico
il cerimoniale
per i matrimoni
poi l'arcivescovo
si sveglia
chiedendosi
chissà che messaggio
mi ha mandato
Dio con questo sogno
a noi che abbiamo letto
il dottor Freud
viene da dire
che l'arcivescovo
sapeva
che c'era qualcosa
che non andava
tanto bene
nel fatto che
la moglie del re
era una principessa
straniera e cattolica
e però il re
ormai non può più
sposare la figlia
di un bravo protestante
ce l'ha già
la moglie cattolica
sta di fatto
che questi dubbi
l'arcivescovo
se gli venivano in sogno
di giorno
li dimenticava
e di giorno
procedeva
implacabile
col suo programma
e quindi
i puritani
vorrebbero distruggere
le immagini sacre
e perfino
i crocifissi
gli altari
l'arcivescovo
impone
vetrate
organi
clero
incotta
l'obbligo
di inginocchiarsi
per la comunione
candele
immagini sacre
il prete
che si inchina
all'altare
il segno
di croce
a giudizio
dei puritani
smorfie
da scimmie
e ovviamente
il programma
dell'arcivescovo
prevede
la liquidazione
delle sette dissidenti
bisogna ristabilire
la disciplina
i puritani
leggono la bibbia
e poi si mettono
a predicare
e sono bravi
a fare i sermoni
a tenere le prediche
ma l'arcivescovo
decide che di prediche
se ne sentono anche
troppe in questo paese
il popolo
non ha bisogno
di prediche
ha bisogno
di catechismo
deve imparare
a memoria
ciò che deve sapere
e non deve
preoccuparsi d'altro
e quando un parroco
o anche un vescovo
non è tanto d'accordo
perché il sospetto
che tutto questo
voglia dire
tornare al cattolicesimo
è diffuso
in questo paese
che ha imparato
appunto
ad avere una paura
maledetta
dei papisti
ecco
quando un vescovo
o un parroco
non è d'accordo
viene sostituito
licenziato
magari messo anche
in galera
i puritani
che si sentono
più in pericolo
scappano dal paese
sapete tutti
dove vanno
vanno in America
avete presente
una delle leggende
fondanti
della storia americana
i padri pellegrini
che arrivano
col Mayflower
e fondano
le colonie
puritane
del New England
e quando ci vanno
ci vanno
negli anni di Carlo
e dell'arcivescovo
Lod
ce ne vanno
talmente tanti
di questi puritani
in America
che il re
anziché essere contento
si preoccupa
che il paese
rischia di perdere
sudditi
per un momento
Carlo pensa
di proibire
le migrazioni
in America
poi non lo fa
il fatto sta
che per un puritano
che se ne va
ce ne sono dieci
che operano
clandestinamente
nel paese
ora
fin qui
di nuovo
medioevo
e modernità
non c'è mica
niente di diverso
rispetto a quello
che succedeva
già nel medioevo
quando la società
cristiana
era piena
di ribelli
di dissidenti
di gente
che non ci credeva
ma adesso
nel 600
c'è una enorme
differenza
c'è la stampa
e la stampa
vuol dire
che nel regno
circola
innumerevoli
trattati
sermoni
preghiere
orazioni
prediche
libelli
a difesa
dei bravi
protestanti
perseguitati
dal re
e dal suo
arcivescovo
amici
dei papisti
in teoria
c'è una legge
sul controllo
della stampa
non si può pubblicare
niente senza
autorizzazione
ma l'apparato
statale
è troppo debole
a quell'epoca
per farla rispettare
tutti stampano
quello che vogliono
clandestinamente
l'arcivescovo
deve accontentarsi
quando riesce
a mettere le mani
su qualcuno
che ha scritto
e pubblicato
qualcosa di sbagliato
l'arcivescovo
deve accontentarsi
di dare qualche esempio
ve ne cito uno
c'è un puritano
che si chiama
William Prynne
è un puritano
al 100%
uno che
critica
gli uomini
che portano
i capelli lunghi
moda dei giovani
nobili di corte
in quell'epoca
e critica
le donne
che portano
i capelli corti
come si permettono
di confondersi
con gli uomini
William Prynne
è uno di quelli
che appunto
vorrebbero abolire
non soltanto
il teatro
ma addirittura
la festa di Natale
è uno che sostiene
che brindare
alla salute
di qualcuno
è già una cosa
è una cosa
diabolica
un peccato
e pubblica
William Prynne
pubblica
un libricino
in cui critica
il teatro
e in particolare
le attrici
perché al tempo
di Shakespeare
non si vedevano
donne sulla scena
le parti femminili
le facevano i ragazzi
ma ormai
anche questo tabù
è caduto
le donne salgono
sul palcoscenico
agli occhi di William Prynne
è una cosa
è una dimostrazione
dell'abisso morale
in cui sta sprofondando
l'Inghilterra
perciò
in questo suo libro
condanna
in particolare
le attrici
peccato
che la regina
a corte
ha appena partecipato
una rappresentazione
recitando lei stessa
davanti ai cortigiani
risultato
il libro di William Prynne
viene considerato
un oltraggio
alla corte
perciò
Prynne viene acchiappato
condannato
alla gogna
al taglio
delle orecchie
e al carcere
a vita
è il 1634
dopodiché
incarcerato
nella torre di Londra
Prynne riesce
a continuare a scrivere
e a pubblicare
scrive un altro libello
in cui
protesta contro il fatto
che in Inghilterra
ormai è nata
una specie di inquisizione
cattolica
che dà la caccia
ai veri protestanti
riesce a farlo pubblicare
lo scoprono
nel 1637
l'anno in cui
il re era scappato
di dire che lui
era il re più felice
della cristianità
nel 1637
Prynne
che è già in galera
nella torre
viene di nuovo
condannato alla gogna
a tagliare
il pezzetto di orecchia
che gli avevano lasciato
la prima volta
e a essere
marchiato a fuoco
sulle guance
con le lettere
S e L
libellista
sedizioso
la folla
che lo vede portare
alla gogna
lo acclama
come un martire
sparge fiori
erbe odorose
sulla strada
che deve percorrere
urla e protesta
contro la polizia
il boia
lo tratta
in modo particolarmente
brutale
al momento in cui
deve marchiarlo
detto fra parentesi
risulta che in queste
occasioni
il condannato
aveva la possibilità
di pagare una bustarella
al boia
e in base a quanto pagava
veniva trattato
più o meno bene
Prynne non deve aver pagato
la gente è furiosa
e grida
se fosse stato
un papista
non gli sarebbe
successo niente
perché appunto
la brava gente
di Inghilterra
è sempre più convinta
che il re
e i suoi cortigiani
in cuor loro
sono dei papisti
in realtà
Carlo è un protestante
convinto
però non è un fanatico
e per esempio
in politica estera
si è alleato
con la Spagna
e la Spagna
è un grande regno
cattolico
certo
però è nemico
della Francia
anche noi
siamo nemici
della Francia
e quindi Carlo
fa una politica
di alleanza
con la Spagna
per molta gente
in Inghilterra
allearsi con la Spagna
vuol dire fare
il patto
col diavolo
poi in Inghilterra
cattolici
ce ne sono ancora
non è vietato
essere cattolici
anche perché
molti lord
e gentiluomini
sono rimasti
attaccati
alla vecchia religione
non hanno diritti
civili
di nessun genere
però non vengono
perseguitati
ci sono leggi
ferocissime
contro il clero
cattolico
è vietato
il culto cattolico
ovviamente
in un paese
protestante
e per un inglese
è proibito
essere un prete
cattolico
la legge dice
che se un prete
cattolico
suddito inglese
viene arrestato
nel regno
deve essere
condannato a morte
ma il re
non fa applicare
veramente
queste leggi
i preti ci sono
nessuno li arresta
ci sono perfino
i frati francescani
clandestini
ma tutti lo sanno
e poi la regina
è cattolica
e per la regina
a corte
si celebra
la messa cattolica
io spero
che cominciate
a capire
cosa vuol dire
per un artigiano
della city
o per un piccolo
proprietario terriero
dello Yorkshire
sentir dire
che a corte
ci sono preti
cattolici
che celebrano
la messa cattolica
per la regina
e i cortigiani
ci vanno
perché è di moda
farsi vedere
alla messa
della regina
il re non ci va
ma la gente
crede di sì
poi il re
ogni tanto davvero
discute volentieri
con i preti cattolici
di sua moglie
la regina
ha una piccola
comunità di cappuccini
una volta
il re va a trovarli
si ferma a mensa
con loro
tutte queste cose
danno adito
a una marea
di libelli
di scritti
insultanti
che girano
in tutto il regno
che tutti leggono
i bravi puritani
si convincono
che il re
è deciso
a riportare
il paese
al papismo
eppure
nei rapporti
dell'arcivescovo
al re
si descrive
una popolazione
devota
obbediente
fedele
la campagna
per il rastribilimento
dell'autorità
va benissimo
non c'è da preoccuparsi
di niente
e proprio
per la sicurezza
che va tutto bene
il re
e per la sicurezza
che Dio
è con lui
naturalmente
perché questo
è fondamentale
sicuro
che va tutto bene
e che Dio
è dalla sua parte
il re si impegna
in un altro scontro
parallelo al primo
che egualmente
gli deve permettere
di affermare
la sua autorità
e che invece
sarà la sua rovina
e cioè
lo scontro
col Parlamento
che cos'è il Parlamento?
dagli studi
fatti a scuola
vi ricordate tutti
che a un certo punto
si comincia a parlare
di monarchia assoluta
di sovrani
assoluti
si comincia a parlarne
nel 500
soprattutto nel 600
il re sole
quando si parlava
del Medioevo
non avete mai sentito
parlare
di sovrani
assoluti
perché un re
del Medioevo
aveva un forte limite
a suo potere
non era superiore
alla legge
e non era in grado
di introdurre
nuove tasse
senza
senza garantirsi
il consenso
del paese
senza consultare
il paese
come faceva
un re del Medioevo
a consultare il paese
quando aveva bisogno
di soldi
convocava
un'assemblea
in cui venivano
i nobili
e venivano
i vescovi
la nobiltà
il clero
e poi venivano
i mercanti
delle città
che erano quelli
che avevano i soldi
in Francia
si comincia a dire
il terzo stato
a un certo punto
queste assemblee
che nei vari paesi
avevano mille nomi
ma in Inghilterra
si chiamava già allora
il Parlamento
queste assemblee
venivano convocate
e dovevano essere
d'accordo
se il re
chiedeva
soldi
ma i re del Seicento
trovano
sempre più faticoso
sottomettersi
a questo obbligo
dopo tutto
non è Dio
che li ha messi sul trono
e allora dovrebbero
rispondere
soltanto a Dio
Carlo è cresciuto
respirando questo clima
suo padre Giacomo
era uno che diceva
i re
siedono sul trono
di Dio
e Dio stesso
li chiama
dei
Giacomo aveva scritto
un manuale
per istruire
suo figlio Carlo
al suo futuro
mestiere di re
in cui gli insegnava
che il re
deve essere un padre
per il suo popolo
ma come ogni padre
ha diritto di vita
e di morte
e ha diritto
a un'obbedienza
assoluta
e Giacomo
insegnava
al suo figlio
che il re
è superiore
alla legge
non è limitato
da nessuna legge
perché è lui
che fa le leggi
e se vuole
le abolisce
Carlo dedica
la sua vita
a realizzare
questi principi
il che in concreto
vuol dire
provare a governare
senza
convocare
il Parlamento
anche altri
re europei
lo fanno
e ci riescono
alla lunga
in Inghilterra
è un'impresa
particolarmente difficile
perché l'Inghilterra
è il paese
dove il Parlamento
ha acquistato
più spazio
e dove già
nel Medioevo
i re
hanno dovuto
giurare
di non governare
senza il consenso
del paese
avete presente
la Magna Carta
e che cos'è
se non
l'impegno
del re
di convocare
il Parlamento
ogni volta
che deve prendere
qualche decisione
importante
il Parlamento
in Inghilterra
sono
potete immaginarlo
tutti
la Camera dei Lord
dove siedono
i Gran Signori
e i Vescovi
e quelli in genere
vanno dove vuole
il re
ma la Camera
veramente importante
è la Camera
dei Comuni
che rappresenta
l'aristocrazia
della campagna
la Gentry
come dicono
gli inglesi
che è la classe sociale
che governa
il regno
perché non esiste
un apparato statale
il re può governare
nella misura
in cui i gentiluomini
di campagna
mantengono l'ordine
fanno da giudici
riscuotano le tasse
e poi oltre
alla Gentry
appunto ci sono
quelli che hanno i soldi
quelli che hanno
i contanti
i mercanti
delle città
la City
di Londra
questa è la Camera
dei Comuni
e ogni volta
che Carlo
nei primi anni
del suo regno
convoca il Parlamento
scopre che
ai Comuni
tutto quello
che chiede
c'è qualcuno
che non è d'accordo
e si alza sempre
qualcuno a parlare
contro le sue richieste
e a mettere in discussione
la sua politica
i Parlamenti
vengono convocati
stanno in sessione
per un po' di tempo
poi vanno a casa
magari per qualche anno
non ce n'è bisogno
ma quando c'è bisogno
si convoca di nuovo
e il re convoca
un nuovo Parlamento
e si ritrova
le stesse facce
dell'altra volta
perché nel paese
nelle contee
ci sono quelli
che hanno fatto ormai
esperienza
e si fanno eleggere
e vanno apposta
in Parlamento
per dire al re
che il paese
non è d'accordo
con la sua politica
in altre parole
non so se capite
in questo paese
che a suo modo
è un laboratorio
di modernità
sta nascendo
il concetto
di opposizione
in teoria
non ci si aspetta
che il Parlamento
per principio
sia contro
le richieste del re
le discute
poi grosso modo
cerca di venire incontro
invece nel Parlamento
inglese
c'è l'opposizione
un gruppo
consistente
ai comuni
che per principio
non è d'accordo
con quello che vuole il re
Carlo ogni volta
che covoca
il Parlamento
fa sempre più fatica
per ottenere
quello che vuole
e alla fine
si stanca
nel 1629
il re dichiara
che siccome
il Parlamento
si oppone
alla sua politica
lui
non lo convocherà più
molti parlamentari
protestano
e finiscono
in prigione
e a partire
da quel momento
per dieci anni
Carlo governa
senza più
convocare
il Parlamento
e può illudersi
può dirsi
di essere diventato
un sovrano
assoluto
senza più vincoli
il problema
è che
i suoi ministri
non sono mica
tanto sicuri
che si possano
davvero mettere
delle nuove tasse
senza convocare
il Parlamento
e senza che il Paese
si ribelli
non osano farlo
però di soldi
c'è bisogno
e dunque
il re
è costretto
a cercare
di far soldi
con altri mezzi
dove li cerchi
i soldi
dove ci sono
nell'economia
nel commercio
fare soldi
vuol dire
non possiamo
mettere nuove tasse
però possiamo dire
per esempio
che tutti quelli
tutti gli straccivendoli
di Londra
devono iscriversi
a una corporazione
e devono pagare
una licenza
per poter fare
il loro mestiere
altrimenti no
e si fa così
e si introduce
tutta una serie
di controlli
di obblighi
di tasse
di fatto
sull'attività commerciale
si introducono
e naturalmente
lo scopo è
prendere soldi
e poi controllare
e beccare i violatori
e multarli
si concedono
i monopoli
vi dicevo
vi faccio un esempio
ho esitato a lungo
se fare questo esempio
perché ve l'ho detto
sarà una lezione lunghetta
quella di stasera
ma
poi ho deciso
che ve lo faccio
lo stesso
perché uno non si immagina
che in un regno del 600
potessero succedere
cose così
dunque
il re
il re concede
a un imprenditore
il monopolio
della fabbricazione
del sapone
l'imprenditore
ovviamente
paga un sacco di soldi
per essere
l'unico
in Inghilterra
che può produrre sapone
chiudono tutte
le altre fabbriche
ovviamente
si crea già
un mondo di scontenti
il monopolista
fabbrica sapone
siccome è l'unico
che lo fabbrica
non deve preoccuparsi
troppo della qualità
dopo un po'
nel regno
si diffonde
la protesta
perché il sapone
del re
è di pessima qualità
il governo
decide di dimostrare
al paese
che non è vero
dite che è di cattiva qualità
vediamo
si organizzano
dei test
in pubblico
convocando le lavandaie
ma i test
vengono truccati
in modo da far risultare
che il sapone
del re va benissimo
risultato
si comincia a produrre
sapone
di contrabbando
e in tutto il paese
la gente compra
il sapone
di nascosto
perché è stato prodotto
senza l'autorizzazione
del re
dopodiché
il re comincia
a mandare in giro
delle spie
per vedere
se riusciamo a beccare
quelli che fabbricano
il sapone di nascosto
e nel mondo
degli artigiani
degli industriali
si comincia a dire
ci sono le spie
del re in giro
attenzione
si crea questo clima
per cui tutto quello
che uno fa
ha sempre l'impressione
che c'è dietro
uno che ti spia
e che andrà
a riferire al re
potete immaginare
quanto a Giovi
questo
alla popolarità
del re
alla fine della guerra civile
qualcuno dirà
che il re
se l'è voluta
proprio con questi
mezzucci
che si è inventato
per far soldi
vi cito da un discorso
proprio dell'epoca
in cui il re
è stato giustiziato
quante povere
venditrici di mele
quanti fabbricanti
di scope
quanti straccivendoli
hanno dovuto vendere
o impegnare
letti e vestiti
per comprarsi
la licenza
di entrare
nelle nuove
corporazioni
del re
a Londra
e quando l'ebbero
acquistata
si vide
che era tutto
un imbroglio
e così il re
si riempì
i forzieri
con l'oppressione
il re
non lo dichiara
ma tutti sanno
che fa questo
per non dover
convocare il parlamento
e poi tenta
l'esperimento
decisivo
finora sono mezzucci
ma adesso proviamo
a introdurre
proprio una nuova
tassa
e vediamo
se il paese
paga
lo fa molto abilmente
al tempo di Elisabetta
c'era una tassa
che veniva pagata
dalle zone costiere
per mantenere
la flotta da guerra
e l'Inghilterra
è un paese
che per tradizione
ha bisogno
di avere una flotta
a difesa delle sue coste
e che tutto sommato
paga volentieri
per questo
perciò il re
ovviamente al tempo
di Elisabetta
la tassa
la ship money
la chiamavano
la tassa per le navi
la ship money
al tempo di Elisabetta
serviva
c'era l'invincibile armada
che veleggiava
verso l'Inghilterra
al tempo di Carlo
la minaccia
non è così evidente
però è vero
che ci sono pirati
nella manica
pirati olandesi
francesi
ci sono addirittura
dei casi
in cui pirati
barbareschi
che arrivano
dal Mediterraneo
sbarcano in cornovaglia
a saccheggiare
a portare via schiavi
insomma il re
dice all'opinione pubblica
siamo in emergenza
e perciò
io chiedo
di nuovo
alle zone costiere
di pagare
la tassa
e le zone costiere
pagano
l'anno dopo
il re
decide di far
pagare
la ship money
non più soltanto
alle città costiere
alle contee
marittime
ma a tutto
il regno
e il passo
successivo
e stavolta
non ce la fa
perché
nell'opinione pubblica
immediatamente
comincia a serpeggiare
la protesta
e la protesta
è formulata così
se vuole
che paghiamo
che convochi
il Parlamento
ci sono lord
che dicono
in faccia
al re
che loro diranno
ai loro contadini
di non pagare
se invece
il re
convoca il Parlamento
e li sta a sentire
allora
tutti pagheranno
volentieri
finalmente
un gentiluomo
fa di tutto
per farsi
processare
in modo
da far scoppiare
la cosa
questo gentiluomo
viene processato
a Londra
davanti al Tribunale
Supremo del Regno
per avere
incitato
i suoi dipendenti
a non pagare
e i giudici
del Tribunale Supremo
si spaccano
perché una metà
dicono
ricordate
quello che diceva
il re Giacomo
il re è superiore
alla legge
loro che sanno
il latino
lo dicono così
in anglo latino
rex
is lex
il re
è la legge
e quindi
può fare
quello che vuole
ma una parte
dei giudici
nominati
dal re
una parte
dei giudici
dicono che
no non è vero
il re
non può
spingersi
fino a quel
punto
perché se dovessimo
ammettere
che il re
può costringerci
a pagare
delle tasse
senza chiedere
il nostro
consenso
cioè senza
convocare il
Parlamento
mi capite
se dovessimo
ammettere
questo
vuol dire
che non c'è più
la difesa
della proprietà
privata
e la proprietà
è sacra
è più sacra
dell'autorità
del re
messo sul trono
da Dio
una parte
dei giudici
dichiara
che
il re
non ha il diritto
di mettere
le mani
nelle tasche
dei suoi sudditi
perché se lo facesse
il principio
di proprietà
salta
e questo
tenetelo presente
perché la rivoluzione
inglese
la guerra civile
è anche una rivoluzione
vado bene
tutte e due
le definizioni
la rivoluzione
inglese
è la prima
grande rivoluzione
borghese
nel senso
che non è
una rivolta
per cambiare
la società
è una rivolta
per garantire
la proprietà
privata
come vedete
siamo già di fronte
a un paese
spaccato
e a un re
che va in rotta
di collisione
contro enormi
interessi
collettivi
senza neanche
rendersi conto
della gravità
della sua posizione
ma la scintilla
che farà precipitare
la guerra civile
è ancora un'altra
è una scintilla
che scocca
nell'altro regno
di cui Carlo è re
la Scozia
il regno unito
che per il momento
esiste ancora adesso
era nato
proprio al tempo
di Giacomo
il padre di Carlo
Giacomo
re di Scozia
era diventato
anche re d'Inghilterra
a quell'epoca
in realtà
non si parla ancora
di regno unito
perché non è unito
per niente
sono due regni
completamente separati
ognuno con le sue leggi
col suo parlamento
con la sua chiesa
e proprio
la chiesa di Scozia
rappresenta
questo è il principale problema
perché l'arcivescovo
di Canterbury
vuole introdurre
il rituale
e le regole anglicane
anche
nell'altro regno
anche nel regno
di Scozia
ma la Scozia
la Scozia è calvinista
per gli scozzesi
e non solo
per appunto
un'avanguardia
di puritani
ma per la massa
in Scozia
le cose che piacciono
tanto all'arcivescovo
l'incenso
le immagini sacre
ecco
sono superstizioni
papiste
oltretutto
agli scozzesi
come potete immaginare
l'idea
che la loro chiesa
la Kirk
come la chiamano loro
sia costretta
ad adottare
le stesse regole
della chiesa
degli inglesi
a loro
ovviamente
sembra un attentato
alla loro indipendenza
e poi
e poi appunto
calvinisti
come sono
ancora più
dei puritani inglesi
gli scozzesi hanno il terrore
che dietro tutto questo
ci sia
quella realtà
mostruosa
che è Roma
il Papa
la meretrice
come disse
un lord scozzese
sono andato a letto
con tante puttane
ma non ci andrò mai
con la puttana
di Babilonia
Roma
ovviamente
e invece
il re e l'arcivescovo
sono decisi
a piegare
la Scozia
e vanno
alla prova
di forza
c'è il nuovo
messale
anglicano
il Book of Common Prayer
e domenica
28 luglio
il nuovo
messale
viene ufficialmente
imposto
in Scozia
a Edimburgo
la folla
si raduna
fuori dalla cattedrale
e picchia
sulle porte
sbarrate
mentre l'arcivescovo
celebra la messa
dentro una cattedrale
vuota
la folla
tira pietre
alle vetrate
della cattedrale
durante tutto il servizio
in teoria
la Scozia
è governata
da un consiglio
del re
che risiede a Edimburgo
e che dovrebbe
far eseguire
i suoi ordini
il consiglio
dichiara
che questa rivolta
è un tradimento
ma lo fa
dopo essersi
rinchiuso
nel castello
di Holyrood
al sicuro
dalla folla
di Edimburgo
e contemporaneamente
per prudenza
il consiglio del re
sospende
l'applicazione
del nuovo messale
nelle chiese
di Scozia
il re
quando è informato
non è d'accordo
ordina di re
introdurre il messale
e di perseguire
immediatamente
i rivoltosi
in Scozia
arrestare i rivoltosi
si rivela
completamente impossibile
l'intero paese
è in piazza
si dice
di qualche vescovo
che per riuscire
a celebrare il rito
secondo il messale
anglicano
si presenta
all'altare
con due pistole
cariche
di fatto
il paese
non intende
accettare
non sono ancora
alla rivolta
contro il re
mandano al re
una supplica
firmata
da moltissimi
nobili
scozzesi
e borghesi
ed ecclesiastici
chiedendo
il ritiro
del libro
di preghiere
notate anche qui
la modernità
che viene fuori
la raccolta
di firme
come gesto
politico
noi mandiamo
al re
una richiesta
e sotto
questa richiesta
ci sono tante
firme
di gente
che conta
il re
per tutta risposta
nel febbraio
del 38
risponde appunto
che tutti i dissidenti
si devono sottomettere
immediatamente
se vogliono evitare
la sua ira
questo proclama
del re
viene letto
a Edimburgo
davanti a una folla
furibonda
e per risposta
in scozzia
nobili
ed ecclesiastici
scozzesi
stendono
un documento
che chiamano
il national
covenant
il patto
nazionale
in cui si dichiara
che nessuno
accetterà mai
che le regole
della chiesa
nazionale
di scozzia
siano modificate
neanche se lo vuole
il re
il covenant
viene letto
in tutte le chiese
di scozzia
e per giorni
e giorni
la gente
fa la fila
per firmare
gli analfabeti
giurano
in massa
in ginocchio
piangendo
il clima
è di entusiasmo
millenaristico
c'è il diario
di un avvocato
di Edimburgo
che scrive
oggi si è celebrato
il grande matrimonio
della nazione
con Dio
noi e Israele
siamo le uniche
due nazioni
che hanno giurato
fedeltà
al Signore
il primate
di Scozia
l'arcivescovo
di Sant'Andrius
fugge a Londra
dichiarando
tutto quello
che abbiamo fatto
in questi 30 anni
è stato distrutto
in un giorno
e il consiglio
del re
da Edimburgo
scrive al re
che visti i risultati
dei suoi ordini
loro
non sono più in grado
di farli applicare
e naturalmente
la notizia
di quello
che è successo
si diffonde
in tutto il regno
d'Inghilterra
perché c'è la stampa
e il covenant
scozzese
il patto
degli scozzesi
viene stampato
in mille tipografie
clandestine
e distribuito
l'arcivescovo
Lode
annota nel suo diario
a Londra
ce l'hanno in mano
tutti
il buffone
di corte
di re Carlo
Archie Armstrong
perché il re
ovviamente
aveva i buffoni
di corte
aveva un gigante
Mackel John
Mackel è dialettale
per dire
grande
e aveva un nano
e aveva un buffone
e il buffone
di corte
incontrando
l'arcivescovo
di Canterbury
dopo che sono arrivate
queste notizie
dalla Scozia
gli chiede
chi è il buffone
adesso?
Ovviamente
viene subito
cacciato dall'impiego
e licenziato
e in Scozia
i sostenitori
del covenant
che ormai tutti
chiamano i
covenanters
sono al potere
e si comincia
a parlare
di espellere
dalla Scozia
tutti quelli
che rifiutano
di firmare
vedete come si scivola
rapidamente
nell'interpretazione
estrema
gli ecclesiastici
considerati
un po' troppo freddi
vengono aggrediti
dalla gente
per strada
e come succede
in questi casi
qualcuno
comincia ad aver paura
che forse
ci siamo spinti
troppo oltre
qualcuno
comincia ad aver paura
che tutto questo
potrebbe portare
anche a dei risultati
che noi non vogliamo
la rivoluzione
sociale
questa cosa
lo esprime bene
uno dei principali
poeti scozzesi
di quell'epoca
William Drummond
uno che poi
durante la guerra civile
si schiererà
col re
William Drummond
scrive
chissà se tutto
questo scompiglio
e tutte queste
discordie
non si trasformeranno
in un bellum
servile
avete presente
Spartaco
le rivolte
degli schiavi
in cui braccianti
buffoni
fattori
insomma
tutta la gentaglia
in armi
inghiottirà
i nobili
e i gentiluomini
si impadronirà
dei loro beni
e si unirà
in un nuovo
covenant
come abbiamo
fatto noi
capite la meraviglia
di questo
come abbiamo
fatto noi
il covenant
l'abbiamo fatto
noi
i signori
i padroni
i ricchi
i nobili
i gentiluomini
il clero
e la marmaglia
la marmaglia
c'è il rischio
che prenda
questa cosa
sul serio
il primo luglio
del 1638
il re Carlo
dichiara ufficialmente
che in Scozia
è in corso
una ribellione
e che lui
intende
stroncarla
con la forza
ora in Inghilterra
questa guerra
è estremamente
impopolare
la brava gente
preferirebbe
mille volte
che il re
facesse la guerra
alla Spagna
invece con la Spagna
papista
il re va ad amore
d'accordo
chissà come mai
e adesso
vuole farci fare
la guerra
contro i nostri
fratelli protestanti
gli scozzesi
in giro
si impreca
contro l'arcivescovo
il papa di Londra
e gli scozzesi
naturalmente
stampano
un appello
al popolo inglese
che circola
in tutta l'Inghilterra
clandestinamente
il re va avanti
duro
però si scopre
che non ci sono
i soldi
per fare questa guerra
contro la Scozia
e qualcuno
gli dice
eh
se non ci sono
i soldi
tu lo sai
cosa devi fare
vero
combo che
no
il re rifiuta
di convocare
un parlamento
piuttosto
prende i soldi
in prestito
si indebita
fino al collo
lo stesso
non riesce
a mettere
insieme
abbastanza soldi
recluta un esercito
scadente
debole
va lo stesso
al nord
nella primavera
del 39
il re marcia
verso la Scozia
arrivato alla frontiera
viene a sapere
che la Scozia
è interamente
in mano al nemico
tutti gli arsenali
i presidi
le fortezze
sono stati occupati
dai covenanters
compreso il castello
di Edimburgo
le guarnigioni
rege
in Scozia
sono passate
dalla parte
dei ribelli
il re rimane lì
sulla frontiera
con questo suo esercito
troppo debole
scontento
dall'altra parte
si sono accampati
gli scozzesi
armati
fino ai denti
dal loro campo
si sentono
i sermoni
dei predicatori
e il canto
collettivo
dei salmi
i lord
che sono lì
al campo
con il re
cominciano a dirgli
che non è il caso
di invadere la Scozia
e che se proprio
ci tiene a farlo
deve convocare
prima il Parlamento
il re ammette
che per il momento
non è abbastanza forte
per invadere la Scozia
fa una tregua
in realtà
avrebbe solo intenzione
di perdere tempo
di prendere tempo
ma
i suoi consiglieri
insistono
questa cosa
è troppo grossa
non si può fare
senza convocare
il Parlamento
l'arcivescovo
è uno dei primi
che glielo dicono
un altro
che glielo dice
con insistenza
è un personaggio
che non ho ancora citato
ma che in quest'ultima
mezz'ora no
se Dio vuole
in quest'ultima
quarto d'ora
venti minuti
citeremo ancora
perché è protagonista
poi di un episodio
drammatico
è il conte di Stratford
governatore
dell'Irlanda
uno dei principali
e più fidati
consiglieri del re
sia l'arcivescovo
Lod
sia il lord Stratford
insistono
bisogna
convocare
il Parlamento
e il re
lo convoca
dopo dieci anni
undici anni
che non lo faceva
il Parlamento
si riunisce
il 13 aprile
del 1640
il re
presenzia
all'apertura
ma non fa lui
il discorso
anche perché
il re
balbetta
leggermente
parlando con qualcuno
che aveva lo stesso difetto
una volta Carlo
gli aveva detto
ho provato a tenere
dei sassolini
in bocca
ma non serve a niente
perciò a suo nome
parla il primo ministro
il cancelliere
il quale
il quale spiega
al Parlamento
che nessun popolo
ha mai avuto
la benedizione
di un re così buono
di una regina
così virtuosa
e che il buon popolo
inglese
deve essere grato
e aiutare il re
a sopprimere
la rivolta
dei malvagi
scozzesi
e se il Parlamento
concederà
i soldi
poi il re
raddrizzerà
tutti i torti
ma il Parlamento
è inondato
di petizioni
il meccanismo politico
è questo
i deputati
delle contee
arrivano a Londra
portandosi dietro
le lettere
che hanno ricevuto
dai loro vicini
dalle comunità
dai ricchi
dai nobili
i quali tutti
hanno qualcosa
contro cui protestare
la tassa delle navi
i monopoli
la politica religiosa
del re
e i comuni
cominciano a nominare
delle commissioni
di nuovo
un laboratorio
di modernità
la camera dei comuni
nomina delle commissioni
dicendo
dobbiamo esaminare
queste petizioni
queste proteste
e il re
se vuole i soldi
deve abolire
la tassa delle navi
e deve
anzi
no non basta
deve raddrizzare
tutti i torti
ascoltare
tutte le proteste
voi potete immaginare
la reazione di Carlo
il 5 maggio
il re
dissolve
il Parlamento
che infatti
è passato alla storia
come lo
short parliament
il Parlamento
breve
due o tre settimane
è la quarta volta
nel suo regno
che Carlo
scioglie il Parlamento
ed è l'ultima volta
che ci riesce
subito dopo
si riunisce il Consiglio
per decidere
come trovare i mezzi
per fare questa
maledetta guerra
alla Scozia
e il governatore
dell'Irlanda
Lord Strafford
dice
forse si potrebbe
reclutare un esercito
in Irlanda
e portarlo
qui
per ridurre
alla ragione
questo regno
sul momento
nessuno ci fa
troppo caso
tra i ministri
che ascoltano
questa frase
tuttora noi
non sappiamo
se Strafford
voleva dire
quando ha detto
ridurre alla ragione
questo regno
voleva dire
la Scozia
che dobbiamo
ridurre alla ragione
o se invece
aveva in mente
qualcosa di diverso
ma ne riparleremo
fatto sta
che senza il Parlamento
non ci sono i soldi
Carlo
è talmente in difficoltà
che fa contattare
addirittura
il Papa
per sapere
se può avere
un prestito
dall'Italia
per pagare
questa guerra
confisca
i depositi
che i mercanti
di Londra
tenevano
nella zecca reale
anche qui
potete immaginare
quanto questo
contribuisca
a renderlo popolare
la City
di Londra
non ne può più
i mercanti
della City
quando il re
chiede soldi
in prestito
rifiutano
di darglieli
il re
e le procedure
sono queste
fa arrestare
gli assessori
del Comune
di Londra
e minaccia
di impiccarli
se non salteranno
fuori i soldi
ma intanto
i soldi
non saltano fuori
il reclutamento
dell'esercito
va malissimo
nel paese
corrono
tutte le voci
più folli
si dice
che i soldati
reclutati
verranno imbarcati
su navi
col pretesto
di sbarcare
in Scozia
ma che in realtà
li porteranno
a venderli
come schiavi
in America
risultato
il re
non riesce
a radunare
un vero esercito
nel frattempo
gli scozzesi
stanno radunando
un esercito
e il 20 agosto
gli scozzesi
passano
il Tweed
e invadono
l'Inghilterra
al suono
delle cornamuse
e al canto
dei salmi
e il re
riceve
l'ennesima
petizione
stavolta
firmata
da un gran numero
di lord
che gli chiedono
la grazia
per tutti quelli
che sono in galera
perché non hanno
pagato le nuove tasse
o perché non hanno
accettato le riforme
dell'arcivescovo
e soprattutto
e questo è
drammatico
gli dicono
abbiamo sentito
che lord
Strafford
ha proposto
di far venire
un esercito
dall'Irlanda
noi
preghiamo
sua maestà
di non farla
una cosa del genere
tenete presente
cos'è l'Irlanda
per gli inglesi
di quel momento
l'Irlanda
è un paese
selvaggio
che noi abbiamo
conquistato
che stiamo
riempiendo
dei nostri
immigrati
protestanti
ma la popolazione
locale
sono selvaggi
per di più
papisti
feroci
tagliagole
assettati
del nostro
sangue
e in qualche
modo si è sparsa
nel paese
la voce
che lord
Strafford
ha suggerito
di reclutare
un esercito
fra questi
selvaggi
papisti
per venire
a domare
questo regno
cos'è che
intendeva dire
esattamente
e il re
qui devo dire
comincia una pagina
che è una delle più
disonorevoli dal punto di vista
del re
che si dimostra
terribilmente
inadeguato
e incerto
quando si accorge
che l'opinione pubblica
vede
lord Strafford
uno dei suoi consiglieri
più fidati
come la sua anima nera
quello che gli dà
i cattivi consigli
comincia a trattarlo
con freddezza
e anzi
gli suggerisce
di lasciare il paese
perché gli dice
non sono mica sicuro
di poter garantire
la tua
incolumità fisica
lord Strafford
decide di restare
a questo punto
il re
gli dà la sua parola
che qualunque
cosa succede
non deve temere
per la sua vita
tenetelo presente
intanto nel nord
invaso dagli scozzesi
la popolazione protestante
simpatizza con gli scozzesi
e li considera
liberatori
il re
senza un soldo
senza un esercito
è costretto a firmare
un accordo
disonorevole
accettando che
l'esercito scozzese
occupi il nord
dell'Inghilterra
e impegnandosi
a pagare le spese
degli occupanti
dopodiché
l'unica cosa
che gli resta da fare
è convocare
un parlamento
e convoca
quello che passerà
la storia
ovviamente
come il lungo
parlamento
l'elezione di questo
è drammatica
perché tutti hanno
chiarissimo
che si è arrivati
a un punto
di non ritorno
questo parlamento
dovrà fare
grandi cose
per forza
il re fa di tutto
per fare eleggere
persone fidate
non ci riesce
il partito
della corte
viene sconfitto
dappertutto
cortigiani
e funzionari
del re
alla camera
dei comuni
si è calcolato
sono solo
l'11%
meno che
in qualunque
altro parlamento
del resto
le elezioni
si sono fatte
con una campagna
elettorale
in cui lo slogan
dei puritani
era
contro i candidati
del re
non eleggete
questi cortigiani
atei
questi preti
papisti
alle elezioni
hanno partecipato
con un impegno
insolito
gli elettori
più poveri
gli artigiani
i bottegai
che di solito
fanno solo numero
sono abituati
a votare
come dice
il gentiluomo
vicino a casa loro
e invece
stavolta
ci sono state elezioni
con dei radicali
che sono andati
a farsi eleggere
con un programma
di protesta
come disse
un lord
che peraltro
poi si schiererà
col parlamento
contro il re
c'è gente
senza camicia
che pretende
di far valere
il suo voto
quanto il mio
e i puritani
i predicatori
puritani
soffiano sul fuoco
fanno appello
al popolo
voi
voi di infima
levatura
voi gente
comune
common people
voi gente
comune
prendete coraggio
Dio vuole fare
uso della gente
comune
nella grande
opera
di proclamare
il regno
di suo figlio
c'è questo clima
di entusiasmo
religioso
millenaristico
leggere
i fogli di notizie
i giornali
i diari
di quei giorni
in cui arrivano i deputati
è impressionante
quello che si dice
è l'alba
di un bel giorno
di lunga felicità
per questo regno
il parlamento
sarà capace
di costruire
un nuovo mondo
naturalmente
per la grande maggioranza
dei deputati
ai comuni
che sono gentiluomini
o mercanti
il nuovo mondo
non vuol dire
la rivoluzione sociale
assolutamente no
non è questo
quasi nessuno
la vuole
il nuovo mondo
vuol dire
il parlamento
deve insegnare al re
che chi comanda
è il parlamento
e deve difendere
la proprietà privata
dalle tasse del re
e deve eliminare
le novità papiste
che piacciono tanto
all'arcivescovo
il parlamento
si inaugura
il 3 novembre
e stavolta
il re fa
il discorso
di apertura
pur balbettando
si rende conto
che ormai
ci deve mettere la faccia
ci va lui
a chiedere al parlamento
i soldi
per la guerra
contro la Scozia
il parlamento
risponde
un momento
ci sono altre cose
da chiarire prima
per prima cosa
bisogna chiarire
che senza radunare
il parlamento
tu non puoi
imporre nuove tasse
e il re
il re non è in grado
di maneggiarlo
questo parlamento
e i suoi ministri
non sono in grado
di difenderlo
e il re
accetta di riconoscere
che effettivamente
lui
questo diritto
non ce l'ha
ma in realtà
le cose vanno oltre
molto in fretta
cominciano ad assumere
le caratteristiche
di una rivoluzione
in giro si sente dire
che il parlamento
è il vero erede
di Elisabetta
come se Giacomo
e Carlo
non ci fossero mai stati
e che la camera
dei comuni
è investita da Dio
non il re
investito da Dio
ma la camera
dei comuni
entro qualche settimana
dalla convocazione
i comuni
cominciano a comportarsi
come il governo
del regno
a mandare ordini
ai giudici di pace
nelle contee
nel frattempo
già che ci sono
aboliscono la censura
sulla stampa
che già funzionava male
ma che a questo punto
viene abolita del tutto
e poi
e poi gli oratori
che prendono la parola
uno dopo l'altro
cominciano ad attaccare
il re
il re e i suoi ministri
e si comincia
a insistere
su questa cosa
cosa intendeva
Lord Strafford
quando ha detto
di reclutare
un esercito
in Irlanda
bisogna nominare
una commissione
per indagare
l'arcivescovo di Canterbury
in quei giorni
stavolta
non annota
nel suo diario
un sogno
ma annota
un altro fatto
che gli è capitato
che l'ha spaventato
nel suo studio
c'era un grande
suo ritratto
fatto dal famoso
pittore di corte
Van Dyck
entrando nello studio
l'arcivescovo
ha trovato
il proprio ritratto
per terra
caduto dal muro
scrive nel diario
io non sono superstizioso
ma Dio voglia
che non sia
un presagio
nel frattempo
vi ricordate
William Pryn
lo stampatore puritano
come avevano tagliato
le orecchie
marchiato le guance
condannato
al carcere a vita
naturalmente
viene liberato
trionfalmente
e al suo posto
finisce
nella torre di Londra
Lord Strafford
arrestato
per ordine
del Parlamento
e il figlio
di un segretario
del re
ritrova
tra le scartoffie
i verbali
di quella famosa
riunione
in cui
Strafford
aveva parlato
di far venire
un esercito
dall'Irlanda
e li consegna
ai capi
dell'opposizione
il clima
è tale
che ministri
e segretari
del re
cominciano
a imbarcarsi
e scappare
all'estero
ovviamente
nel frattempo
si passa
a una politica
puritana
i preti
cattolici
che prima
giravano
indisturbati
adesso
vengono arrestati
e qualcuno
viene anche
impiccato
e squartato
con enorme
soddisfazione
del buon popolo
puritano
e i comuni
cominciano a passare
leggi religiose
puritane
estremiste
di vieto
di qualunque gioco
la domenica
eliminazione
di tutte le immagini
sacre
dalle chiese
di vieto
di inginocchiarsi
durante il rito
queste smorfie
papiste
appunto
e già che ci sono
sbattono nella torre
anche l'arcivescovo
di Canterbury
e a marzo
del 41
si apre
il processo
di Lord
Strafford
davanti al Parlamento
accusato
un po' di tutto
ma in particolare
di aver voluto
reclutare
un esercito
in Irlanda
per soggiogare
questo regno
cioè
noi
liberi inglesi
è un processo
che dura due mesi
e che suscita
un'emozione gigantesca
le cronache
del tempo
ci dicono
che l'aula
del tribunale
è stratiena
di pubblico
che la gente
bivacca lì
si porta pane
formaggio
birra
si dice che la gente
fa i suoi bisogni
sul posto
pur di non perdere
il posto
e poter assistere
giorno dopo giorno
al processo
Strafford
nonostante tutto
riesce a dimostrare
che lui non voleva
reclutare un esercito
per sottomettere
l'Inghilterra
parlava della Scozia
ma il diritto inglese
prevede
che il Parlamento
può far passare
una legge
c'è uno speciale
tipo di legge
con cui si dichiara
che una certa persona
è un criminale
colpevole
e che va
condannata a morte
anche in assenza
di processo
i comuni
passano
questo tipo
di legge
dichiarando
che il Lord
Strafford
deve essere giustiziato
la legge
deve passare
ai Lord
e poi
alla firma
del re
il re dichiara
che lui
non firmerà
quando passa
ai Lord
la maggior parte
dei Lord
saggiamente
preferisce
non farsi vedere
alla camera
dei Lord
sono pochi
i presenti
e tutto sommato
sono pochi
c'è la folla
che rumoreggia
il re ha già detto
che lui
tanto non firma
perciò i Lord
se ne lavano le mani
e firmano
anche loro
la legge
che condanna a morte
il Lord Strafford
a questo punto
la legge
arriva dal re
e il re
non sa bene
cosa fare
e si consiglia
con i giuristi
con i vescovi
e poi si prende
paura
e firma
salvo pentirsi
subito dopo
ma è troppo tardi
due giorni dopo
Lord Strafford
viene decapitato
e l'arcivescovo
Lod
in prigione
nella torre
annota
nel suo famoso
diario
che non valeva
la pena
di servire
quel re
e fin qui
stiamo finendo
fin qui
sembra di essere
nella Francia
della rivoluzione
francese
quando ogni nuovo
cedimento
del re
lo spinge
sempre di più
verso il baratro
ma stavolta
le cose vanno
un po' diversamente
perché
proprio l'estremismo
del Parlamento
l'estremismo
dei comuni
la violenza
dei puritani
l'esecuzione
di Lord Strafford
cominciano
a spaventare
molta gente
nel Parlamento
stesso
si nota
un cambiamento
di linea
ogni volta
che si vota
c'è una minoranza
sempre più forte
che vota
a favore
del re
fa paura
questa spinta
radicale
che rischia
di diventare
una rivoluzione
voi capite
siano andati
a queste riforme
credendo
di rimediare
a delle ingiustizie
e di tornare
ai buoni
vecchi tempi
di Elisabetta
quando tutto
andava bene
e adesso invece
adesso si stanno
manifestando
delle novità
che nessuno voleva
che nessuno
si aspettava
perlomeno
come se non bastasse
a Londra
c'è la peste
e i capi
dell'opposizione
ai comuni
cominciano a ricevere
lettere di insulti
lettere che li accusano
la peste colpa loro
uno di loro
riceve una busta
con dentro
uno straccio
infetto di peste
o almeno
lo giudica subito
tale ecco
mandato da qualcuno
che non gli vuole bene
e il re ci gioca
il re ha capito
che nel parlamento
c'è sempre più gente
che è spaventata
da quello che sta
succedendo
ci sono sempre più deputati
che può tirare
dalla sua parte
e quindi il re ci gioca
fa sapere al parlamento
che se si continua
così
e qui cito
la gente comune
the common people
finirà per mettersi
per conto proprio
chiamare libertà
l'eguaglianza
e l'indipendenza
tutte brutte parole
chiaramente
distruggere tutti i diritti
e le proprietà
e tutte le distinzioni
di nascita
di merito
il re sa
che sta toccando
una corda
perché i deputati
sono tutti signori
gentiluomini
ogni volta che si vota
appunto
il re conta i voti
della sua minoranza
e questa minoranza
cresce
e finalmente
nel gennaio del 42
il re si sente
abbastanza forte
da tentare
appunto
la prova di forza
si presenta
in parlamento
con i soldati
con un elenco
di parlamentari
da arrestare
non li trova
il parlamento
fa resistenza
i ricercati scappano
e lo speaker
del parlamento
dichiara al re
che lui non è lì
per obbedire a lui
è lì per obbedire
ai comuni
il re a questo punto
lascia Londra
dove il clima
non è favorevole
si rifugia al nord
dove l'opinione pubblica
è maggiormente fedele
e comincia
a reclutare soldati
e anche il parlamento
comincia a reclutare soldati
il re si dirige
alla città di Hull
vicino al confine
scozzese
dove c'è un grande
deposito di armi
messo lì
per la guerra
contro la Scozia
il governatore
della città
rifiuta
di lasciare entrare
il re
il re ordina
che sia arrestato
come traditore
chi lo arresta
impossibile
il re cerca
di prendere Hull
con la forza
viene respinto
il 22 agosto
Carlo
innalza il suo
stendardo
a Nottingham
dichiarando
di essere
in guerra
contro i
ribelli
del Parlamento
e il paese
si spacca
anche il Parlamento
un po' più
della metà
dei deputati
dei comuni
stanno col Parlamento
ma i due quinti
vanno col re
i lord
in grande maggioranza
stanno col re
ma non tutti
circa un quarto
dei lord
stanno col Parlamento
il nord
sta col re
il sud
sta col Parlamento
Londra
i mercanti
i soldi
stanno col Parlamento
c'è un dato
sorprendente
ci sono fatte
come potete capire
tutte le analisi
possibili
su quelli che stanno
da una parte
e quelli che stanno
dall'altra
il dato sorprendente
è questo
i giovani
stanno col re
in media
i deputati
o i lord
che stanno col re
sono molto più giovani
che non quelli
che stanno
col Parlamento
è una cosa
che va spiegata
e in genere
si spiega così
che il progetto
di Carlo
di imporre
il suo assolutismo
non era una cosa
così anacronistica
anzi
era un progetto
in linea
con i tempi
e i giovani
che avevano conosciuto
solo quello
non avevano
necessariamente
un rifiuto
verso questa cosa
il rifiuto
ce l'hanno quelli
più anziani
che si ricordano
un'altra epoca
quando il re
non pretendeva
di essere
un sovrano assoluto
e così scoppia
la guerra
e
naturalmente
fra mille
ti mori
perché tutti
tutti vogliono
vincere
ma tutti hanno paura
che scoppi la rivoluzione
la rivoluzione sociale
che nessuno vuole
invece
come scrive
un deputato
che si è schierato
contro il re
in una guerra civile
non ci saranno
più diritti
proprietà
l'idea
del mio
e del tuo
e chissà
quanto ci guadagnerà
la marmaglia
che già adesso
pensa
che siccome
tutti gli uomini
sono uguali
non c'è ragione
che qualcuno
possegga così tanto
e qualcun altro
così poco
poi il Parlamento
vincerà la guerra
dopo sei lunghi
anni di guerra
e la marmaglia
non ci guadagnerà
nulla
sei anni
di guerra civile
finiranno
come noi stasera
abbiamo cominciato
con la decapitazione
del re
a Whitehall
l'arcivescovo
Lode
l'aveva preceduto
di quattro anni
era stato processato
per tradimento
nel 45
e l'accusa
contro l'arcivescovo
era stata affidata
a nessun altro
che a William Prynne
all'uomo
a cui lui aveva fatto
tagliare le orecchie
William Prynne
pubblico accusatore
nominato dai comuni
fa di tutto
per far condannare
l'arcivescovo
frugare le sue scartoffie
legge il suo diario
suborna i testimoni
non riesce
a farlo condannare
non c'è problema
anche per l'arcivescovo
viene passata
una legge del Parlamento
che lo dichiara
nemico del popolo
e lo condanna a morte
e l'arcivescovo
viene decapitato
quattro anni prima
del suo re
e invece
il patto del popolo
come diceva
quel poeta scozzese
e la rivoluzione sociale
non si realizzeranno
l'idea
che tutti gli uomini
sono uguali
resterà confinata
nei sermoni
di qualche estremista
e chi proverà
a realizzarla
perché qualcuno
ci proverà
ci sono alla metà
del seicento
in Inghilterra
dei movimenti
che sono rimasti
famosi
i livellatori
che volevano appunto
livellare tutti
basta con i ricchi
e con i poveri
quando ci provano
sul serio
scopriranno
che l'esercito
del Parlamento
è prontissimo
a reprimere
nel sangue
a base di fucilazioni
quelli che non hanno capito
che a un certo punto
bisogna fermarsi
ma questa non era
nella prima
e non sarà neanche
l'ultima volta
naturalmente
grazie
grazie a tutti
a domani sera
allora
grazie